that's interesting because now we have
reality TV where it's great it's it's
considered good to have public meltdowns
on camera yeah I know what you're asking
okay go ahead um well I mean what do I
know I'm nobody from nowhere you know so
I'm just a working Joe actor but for me
my job is to help the people who like to
see me do stuff if there are already
people to help them have fun their life
is really really hard and they're not
turning to me for my emotional trauma or
for any problems I'm having they're
turning to me because they say hey that
dude makes me smile it's fun I love
watching him do something heinous if
it's a horror movie are being weird if
it's another movie I like watching him
it's fun and I can't violate that trust
by saying excuse me I I can't let you
have fun right now because I'm going
through something that's not my job if
I'm a plumber I better come in and work
on your pipes not come in and tell you
the me and my wife are having a fight at
breakfast you don't care you didn't hire
me for that so the audience is my boss
and I have to give them what they are
expecting when they buy me or that trust
is violated they're not buying anymore
for me that's that's where an actor's
job is and I think that's what old
Hollywood had it right people went to
see a Jimmy Cagney picture they knew why
and they knew what they were getting my
grandmother started smoking because Joan
Crawford smoked on screen so strong the
influences were because she was a little
heavy set and she went to see his movie
and Joan Crawford was there and she was
a shopgirl tour she's only in a shop
girl and she lit up and they asked for
characters they said why do you smoke
like that and she said keeps me Finn so
ma'am I started smoking that day
she loved your altar because she
identified with it is a tough job girl I
think that's what you have to give
people what they expect from you and
what helps them to have fun we're
entertainers
you